9 uhr am morgen 9 uhr am morgen
nein ich habe verschlafen
heute ist mein erster schultag in der
neuen stadt heute ist mein erster
schultag in der neuen stadt
ich muss mich beeilen sonst verpasse ich
den unterricht
den unterricht so ein stress am morgen
mag ich nicht so ein stress am morgen
mag ich nicht
wo ist mein handy
ich kann es nicht finden
es ist nicht in meinem rucksack
vielleicht unter dem bett vielleicht
unter dem bett
ich schaue zur sicherheit nach ich
schaue zur sicherheit nach
hier ist es nicht
hier ist es nicht so könnte es denn sein
so könnte es denn sein ist es mir in die
umzugskisten gefallen ist es mir in die
umzugskisten gefallen
oh da ist es ja zum glück da ist es ja
zum glück jetzt muss ich duschen gehen
jetzt muss ich duschen gehen
ich liebe das gefühl von warmem wasser
auf meiner haut
auf meiner haut putze noch die zähne
putze noch die zähne fast fertig jetzt
muss ich mich anziehen
fast fertig jetzt muss ich mich anziehen
hmm was soll ich anziehen
hmm was soll ich anziehen das grüne job
gefällt mir das grüne top gefällt mir
ich denke die blauen jeans passen super
dazu
oder ich denke die blauen jeans passen
super dazu oder
draußen ist es heute kalt draußen ist es
heute kalt ich ziehe ein pullover an
ich ziehe ein pullover an das ist mein
lieblings pullover das ist mein
lieblings pullover hat ein schönes roth
hat ein schönes roth
ich habe keine zeit die haare zu
frisieren
ich nehme das rote band
ich darf die schule nicht vergessen ich
darf die schule nicht vergessen
es ist schon 10 uhr es ist schon 10 uhr
ich habe den bus verpasst
es tut mir leid für die verspätung
ich habe verschlafen
ich habe verschlafen kein problem
schön dass du jetzt da bist
kein problem schön dass du jetzt da bist
kannst du dich kurz vorstellen
kannst du dich kurz vorstellen ich heiße
und wohnen in der nähe vom park ich
heiße und wohnen in der nähe vom park
ich bin neu nach zürich gezogen
setz dich jetzt hin
setz dich jetzt hin neben rafael ist ein
platz frei
neben rafael ist ein platz frei
heute lernen wir das werk waren
lernen wir das verb abfahren
der bus fährt bald ab
der bus fährt ab
der bus ist abgefahren
stunden vergehen stunden ergehen
es ist schon vier uhr
ich wünsche euch ein schönes wochenende
nun warte kurz du nimmst auch den bus
zum park stimmt nun warte kurz du nimmst
auch den bus zum park stimmt ja genau
wieso fragst du ja genau wieso fragst du
ich wohne auch da in der nähe vom park
fahren wir zusammen mit dem bus fahren
wir zusammen mit dem bus ja sicher ich
freue mich über deine begleitung ja und
sicher ich freue mich über deine
begleitung dann gehen wir mal los bevor
wir den bus verpassen
dann gehen wir mal los bevor wir den bus
verpassen
oh ja ich habe ihn heute schon einmal
verpasst
dein name ist rafael richtig dein name
ist rafael richtig
ja ich heiße raphael ja ich heiße
raphael musst du schon lange in zürich
willst du schon lange in zürich seit
fünf jahren ja seit fünf jahren
ich bin neu in der stadt
ich bin neu hier in der stadt
zürich ist eine tolle stadt zürich ist
eine tolle stadt
es gibt gute restaurants es gibt gute
restaurants
es gibt schöne parks
es gibt schöne parks ich habe eine idee
ich habe eine idee
wir können zusammen mal eine
stadtrundfahrt machen wir können
zusammen mal eine stadtrundfahrt machen
dann zeige ich dir die verschiedenen
stadtteile und sehenswürdigkeiten
danke gerne das bild
danke gerne das wäre nicht ich kenne
hier noch niemanden
ich kenne hier noch niemanden hier ist
schon meine haltestelle hier ist schon
meine haltestelle ich muss aussteigen
bis bald ich muss aussteigen
bis bald
bis bald mach's gut bis bald mach's gut
ich freue mich jetzt nach hause zu gehen
sechs so am abend sechs so am abend
jetzt bin ich müde jetzt bin ich wieder
ich liebe es in meinem bett zu legen und
zu entspannen
auch wenn ich den morgen verschlafen
habe habe ich heute viel gelernt auch
wenn ich den morgen verschlafen habe
habe ich heute viel gelernt zum beispiel
früher aufzustehen um den lust nicht zu
verpassen
zum beispiel früher aufzustehen um den
wustlich zu verpassen
hat dir das video gefallen
abonniere unseren kanal hat dir das
video gefallen abonniere unseren kanal